you
are a scholar of religious belief or
belief in general
so the fascinating question uh what do
you think is the difference between
our beliefs and objective reality
what is real period sure what is real
easy question so first let me start with
belief
so belief is generally there are
different
definitions of belief just just as there
are different definitions of what is
real
okay so for belief in my field it would
be
attitudes toward something that dictate
our actions
okay so we believe the sun is going to
rise tomorrow
therefore we act as if it will rise
tomorrow all right
beliefs can be wrong for a long time
people believed and actually some still
do that the earth
was flat okay well that's obviously an
erroneous belief
so beliefs can be wrong
now the bigger question that
philosophers ask is um
does is this belief accurate toward what
we consider to be objective reality
so now let me go to objective reality so
what is real
i don't think we can actually obtain
a correct understanding of what is real
and in that sense i have to refer to a
philosopher again
and that would be immanuel kant so
immanuel kant is
one of the he was uh
basically in the 1750s he wrote
critiques of reason and things like that
so he said well if you're a philosopher
or have any kind of understanding of
western history you know who he is
um he had this idea that we can actually
never get to the thing in
itself okay so and he called that the
numeral the thing in itself
he said this let's take this table for
instance that you and i are talking
across
so this thing is a table you and i both
know that we assume
it's real we believe in it because we
put our water on it and our water stays
on it okay
um however can we know this thing um in
and of itself as a table
um so that would be what he then would
call um
the phenomenal how do we know that that
phenomena
exists as we know it is okay
how do we know we use our faculties so
we use our senses and things like that
but again even our senses can be wrong
so
i've been on committees just recently
this year
last year for hiring professors in my
department who
are philosophers and every and we're
hiring metaphysicians and
you know people who are thinking about
the nature of reality and basically what
what i've learned from them yeah they're
very i'd love to attend those faculty
talks
metaphysics professors what's funny is
that right for each one of them
i'm convinced each time they all say
different things but they're so
convincing i'm like yes
hire that one right is it like
historical philosophy
no particular type no they have an
actual belief
they're practicing meta facilities
metaphysicians
yes so what they do is they come and
they're usually
excellent philosophers from harvard or
you know
usc or whatever you know they come and
they give what's called a job talk
that's what floss
every academic does a job talk in order
to get it they talk to us about
a department about what they do and so
it
so happens that we need a metaphysician
and now we're hiring again for one
and so i've learned a lot about
metaphysics in the last year
and this is what i've learned that they
use
physics as a basis for understanding
what we can know about what is real
and what is real is really difficult to
pin down
and so your question is what is belief
well belief
does it correspond to reality that's the
question i would ask
and first we don't even know what what
is real so the table they would say how
do we know that the table even exists
well
how do we differentiate it from the
floor for example so these are the
questions that philosophers are asking
no one else is of course but
philosophers are asking these questions
and they have different answers for it
so i would say that it's very difficult
to know
what is real and in fact what i do
usually is i
paraphrase my friend um and colleague
brother guy consolmano
he's a jesuit priest he's also an
astronomer and he's the director of the
vatican observatory
and so he says this he's a very smart
person he says well
truth is a moving target you know so
so basically to know what is
real out there like gravity or something
like that you've got to approximate it
and as human beings you know we have um
senses
to tell us what at least so we don't get
hurt you know we're not gonna fall off
uh building or something like that we
have eyes to see and things like that so
we can approximate what reality is but
we're never gonna get to it
um unless we develop better senses okay
and i think that that is what we are in
the process of doing we're developing
better senses
we have telescopes we have microscopes
we have you know extensions of ourselves
which are now called technology
and we can get to a better understanding
of what reality is and what the
objective world is
and therefore our beliefs can be honed
so we can get better beliefs more
accurate beliefs but can we get beliefs
that actually correspond to reality
not in any precise way but in
approximate ways
you